the word out on the street is that Conan
O'Brien supports stand-ups this is the
up and up where we take all the people
from the Conan show that we love
put them up live people think I've lost
touch but I know what's happening
President Bush will get us out of this
mess here's the point I am getting to
know men before I sleep with them don't
do that
what am I gonna look like showing up to
a club in Hollywood at one am looking
forward 22 year olds look like
somebody's dad is GD here dude
enjoy a song from talktime
[Applause]
speaking eighties bands which one were
you in sir my tongue so fast it could
get star on chips they chase down the
highway by Erik Estrada don't worry girl
and locally nada on me we're home free
people just presume that poor people are
stupid in fact where people are not
stupid it's a whole goddamn movie it's a
whole Good Will Hunting Oscar Oscar
[Music]
what are you doing who are you why are
you late this is historic
[Music]
we're back
[Music]